Nelson Mandela became South Africa's
first democratically elected president
in 1994 with the official end of white
minority rule otherwise known as
apartheid apartheid you've heard of it
what exactly was it I'm Francesca
Fiorentina and this is a j+ apartheid is
an Afrikaans word that means
separateness it was a system of racial
segregation that governed South Africa
for nearly 50 years it specifically
aimed to protect the domination of the
white South Africans over non-whites in
every aspect of life but it didn't just
appear out of thin air during the
colonial grab for the country between
the Dutch descended afrikaners and the
British the rights of native black South
Africans were sidelined so when
apartheid was officially made law in
1948 by the Afrikaner led National Party
it was a continuation of an justices
already happening Afrikaners believed
that South Africa was their god-given
homeland and that the white race was
superior the black majority was
therefore seen as a threat there were a
hundred and forty-eight apartheid laws
blacks had to carry ID permits at all
times and had to obey strict curfews
public facilities were separated for
white and non-white use and marriages
between whites and other races were
banned people were classified into four
racial categories white black Indian and
colored people of mixed race and they
were all separated into different
residential areas blacks were divided
into ten so-called homelands based on
tribal groups
homelands were rural overcrowded and
lack jobs forcing blacks to seek work as
migrant laborers wages were low and it
was illegal for workers to strike see
apartheid was also economically
motivated a cheap workforce was needed
particularly to work in the country's
gold mines powerful mining magnets had a
huge stake in apartheid policies since
their profits depended on keeping black
wages low outside their designated home
and non-whites had no political rights
since they were not technically citizens
they couldn't vote education also
divided the state set up a separate
education system for blacks that
received a fraction of the funding that
white schools did mandatory education
ended at age 13 and was structured to
funnel blacks into menial migrant labour
exploitation by design needless to say
there was resistance to these insane
laws protests were often led by black
students and youth and were met with
severe repression out of these struggles
came leaders like Nelson Mandela Oliver
Tambo and Walter Sisulu who would help
bring an eventual end to apartheid
so now that you know what apartheid was
could you imagine living under it are
there any similarly unjust laws that
still exist where you live leave us your
comments below peace and reconciliation